each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
i'm going to start really looking at
this largely from an end user
application side to some extent so i'll
talk about what cloud means in the world
of kind of research science ok so how
many of you are kind of computer science
PhDs and how many years sort of non
computer science science PhD ok few v ok
so hopefully this will be of interest to
everyone because there's some pretty
cool science applications but I'll also
explain how they're built under the hood
using cloud computing so so in the
scientific world and we think about
science so think about computer science
as well so back back many centuries ago
millennia ago science was very
observational so people like Galileo
would look up into the sky look at the
stars look at the planets take down
observations of what was happening
Newton Newton Leonardo da Vinci for
instance would sit by the river and see
the water flowing through the river and
see how it would flow around rocks and
you know he would then think about
designing helicopters and airplanes so
very much kind of experimental or
observational ok so that was many
centuries ago then came mathematics and
what that meant was these observations
could be instantiated in mathematics so
does anyone know what that equation is
very famous equation you would die
without it ok it's called navier-stokes
equations now via stokes equations
describe fluid flow everything from the
atmosphere to the oceans to flow around
cars flow around airplanes air in your
lungs blood in your veins and arteries
ok so that equation again from da Vinci
sitting watching rivers we can get to an
equation that can do all that and then
we can get to sometimes you can solve
that equation
so that equation if you can solve that
if you can show that that equation has a
unique solution in two dimensions you
get a million dollars today because no
one's done it done it in one dimension
but showing that there is a single
solution to that equation in two
dimensions nobody has ever achieved okay
so sometimes you can't solve equations
analytically and we can resort to
computers to do simulations so that's an
example of how a weather simulation is
done for weather forecasts and climate
modeling and we typically can do that on
sort of big supercomputers so that's
kind of where science has got to okay
pretty much state of the art but we're
moving into an interesting world where
Jim Gray who is one of the researchers
at Microsoft who actually went missing a
few years ago but was very big in
databases but got interested in science
he coined this idea of the fourth
paradigm of scientific discovery so the
fact that we have data all around us and
we can collect data be that from sensors
be that from simulations be that for
instance from computer networks okay we
can take that data and actually use that
as the basis for hypothesizing about new
science and what that means is the
nature of science is changing okay so
when we think about the first paradigm
of observational science it was very
much you know a single person like
Galileo okay and with mathematicians as
well and some extent with simulation but
we're this data intensive sort of
science it can be much more
collaborative the so the Large Hadron
Collider is an interesting example where
you know teams of thousands of
scientists are actually working together
okay and that's what this fourth
paradigm of science makes it very
interesting what's interesting is we
think about you know the Large Hadron
Collider is a great example of you know
a huge experiment okay where you know
they're colliding particles seeing what
happens and then having to analyze this
huge cascade of data and so it's a sort
of classic example of what we would call
data intensive science a petabyte
of data i went to talk last week
actually where the person in charge of
this gave a talk and the amount of data
just the amount of data per second
coming out of the Large Hadron Collider
is amazing so that's particle physics
but if we think about climate science
okay it's the same astronomy is the same
so there's a project called the Square
Kilometre Array which is being built in
South Africa and Australia and it's it's
looking at you know the night sky in
much more detail than ever before and
they're talking there about exabytes
they're saying in 2018 they'll have
three exabytes of data ok and so if so
those are saw what we call big science
fields but even feels like social
science if you think about Twitter and
you think about Facebook and you think
about the data on phones and how we can
do science around that I can understand
what people do you know that's in this
realm as well as petabytes and petabytes
of data and so this explosion of data so
how many of you heard of the term big
data okay so kind of pretty trendy term
at the moment so big data big science
big data science the case is pretty much
everywhere now and when we think about
how we do science in this new world we
can think about data being in the middle
data is this kind of interesting
resource that people can tap into so if
we start at twelve o'clock you know
typically that the standard scientific
model would be starting here at twelve
o'clock people mess over there okay
where we might design experiment acquire
data from the experiment I'll then sort
of look at my results maybe with some
colleagues I'll then do my analysis okay
and then our basically test my
hypothesis or my null hypothesis and
then I'll publish my paper okay and
share that and then the paper goes to
library and it's archived so think about
that as a linear process whereas now in
this kind of world of data science big
data thinking about data in the middle I
Mike kind of with the Large Hadron
Collider for instance somebody else has
already collected the data and done some
pre analysis and I can come at that
and run my own analysis without having
to do the acquisition myself because the
data is already there and so we're
seeing this increasingly in many
different fields where we want to be
able to tap into existing data okay so
it's a much more sort of holistic way of
doing science so that's where science is
heading in terms of these different sort
of epochs of science in it so it's
pretty exciting for people who work with
computers like us to be in that world so
I'm going to talk about Big Data but in
the context of sort of science not so
much in the commercial world so I want
to show you an interesting tool that
we've built in Microsoft Research called
worldwide telescope this is a
planetarium on your computer okay not
only is it a planetarium on your
computer but it's actually the highest
resolution map of the night sky okay
again all access through your computer
so the problem was that NASA had done
some sky surveys and they had to stitch
together the individual images so
literally a panorama you know like you
do with your camera or phone but for the
whole night sky and you can see the
numbers there are lots and lots of
images lots of data and what's
interesting is you get this kind of
mosaic okay this happens again when you
if you use your camera phone you do
panorama you kind of get a mismatch
because it does the light metering kind
of differently as you change angles
depending where the Sun is so you get
this kind of different effect this
mosaic effect so what we wanted to do is
to create a seamless image of the sky
okay so we had to figure out how to do
that and get rid of these kind of nasty
edges and do the contrast matching etc
and so it's an example of a data
pipeline for processing we're
transitions are all really slow there we
go where we went from the raw data here
and applied lots of different
Corrections and created a pipeline using
dry air dried link which is the kind of
MapReduce type dag framework okay and
you know see doing parallel processing
in.net and here we were using
Windows 8 PC so the supercomputing on
windows in order to process those
gigabytes of data in order to create
this seamless we call a tiled image so
it's like with maps you know bing maps
google maps where you zoom in and out
and it seamlessly zooms in and out the
same thing for the night sky okay so
it's an interesting say big data big
data problem and so we start with the
mosaic type image and ended up with a
very very smooth map of the night sky
and I want to show you what that looks
like what happens if I hit play yes it's
very very difficult to navigate with the
mouse so this shows you essentially that
worldwide telescope sound and so you can
see that you know in the original image
these are all tiles and so we can we can
pan around the night sky but we can also
zoom in into the different galaxies and
you can see how we're overlaying the
constellations you know we can turn
those on and off we can actually put in
different spectra so you can put an
x-ray spectra for instance an overlay
images for instance from Hubble
telescope that's the famous hubble deep
sky image okay that shows the sort of
early universe each one of those is
galaxy okay so pretty incredible that
I've that's one of the pictures from
Hubble that that I always remember and
so you can see how we can stitch this
together an overlay data on our map and
you can see that that great sort of
zooming in and out like they like we get
on you know terrestrial maps but for the
night sky but it required a huge amount
of processing you know we can deliver
this you know over the web we're
switching to a different spectra there
to show so I just wanted to show you
that see so you got a worldwide
telescope org and you can see that so
when we talk about Big Data one of the
interesting things is obviously there's
a lot of data and that can be some big
files or lots of
lots and lots of small files and it gets
quite difficult to handle so one of the
definitions of big data is data you
can't handle using conventional data
systems like databases okay it's kind of
a definition of big data so then to be
able to apply analysis against that
again becomes very difficult and this is
actually where cloud computing can
become very useful because in the cloud
we can ultimately have infinite storage
and infinite compute okay from a Sony
from a technical basis and so what we're
trying to do within certainly our group
and Microsoft Research is to make that
available to people which previously it
was very difficult to have both the
access and the expertise to be able to
manage lots of data and then apply
complex algorithms against the data so
one of the things our team in research
connections is doing is trying to make
that much more accessible through the
desktop through things like Excel where
typically you would just have to do an
awful lot of work to do that so an
example of this is actually from one of
our colleagues david hackman who's
actually based out in California who
works in genomics and I'll talk a bit
more about kind of what he used to do so
on the left-hand axis you can see the
cost and it has lots of zeros behind it
the cost of sequencing a human genome is
dropping this white line is Moore's law
okay so what you can see is that a few
years ago all of a sudden that the
genome sequencing technology advanced so
much that there's this sudden drop in
price where it's becoming much much
cheaper to the point where you will soon
be able to buy that device for about a
thousand dollars and notice what's on
the end of the vice it's a USB plug so
you can plug that into your laptop and
it will sequence your genome for about a
thousand dollars so we're going through
a revolution basically where we're going
to be able to sequence individual
people's genomes personalized genomes
and that's going to create a mound of
data but it's also going to create a
huge amount of opportunity for you know
the medical community to try and
understand disease for instance and
screening and
come up with sort of vaccines for
instance which is what the video will
show you but what I'll do is I'll go
through here and then come back to video
so david has been at Microsoft quite a
long time and he joined in the team that
was doing spam filtering okay so back in
the day spam started out where it wasn't
really a problem and then it became a
problem and so for example what would
happen is that they're working ok that
the spammers would for instance try to
advertise something so for instance
something like viagra right and that
they could put in your email message
something about viagra so the filter
people got ok that's fine we'll do a
search for the word viagra and if the
email has viagra in it will filter out
as junk so the spammers when oh they're
filtering all our stuff so they said are
what we'll do is we'll replace the eye
with a one so the filters didn't spot it
spam would start coming through not
getting filtered so then the spam filter
people we go aha we've noticed that
spammers are replacing eyes with ones
will look for that and will and so they
would then add that to the filter or in
it start putting it in the junk folder
and then the spammers would put out
signs instead of A's then they got
really clever and said we're going to
put a bitmap in that says viagra rights
it's not even text that will fool the
filter people so the filter people at
that point Dave in team they just went
this is nuts this is an arms race
between the spammers and the spam
anti-spam people so they then step back
and said okay well what's the common
thing that all spam email does all spam
email directs you to a website okay
because that's ultimately where they
make money so they said okay why don't
we look for the links to the websites
because every spam email will link to a
website and so they kind of had to think
what's the weak spot in the spammers
technique so what's interesting is that
HIV is similar it mutates so every time
you try and go after it and the immune
system tries to attack it it will mutate
so David and the team
thought okay can we apply that same
logic of going against HIV s weak spot
what's the weak spot in HIV and it turns
out that you can so this is a picture of
HIV okay and what happens I've tried to
highlight here in in red and green two
spots on on HIV where what will happen
is the red spot there will mutate okay
but if it mutates then we want to go
after it and if we go after what
happened is the green protein there will
also mutate okay so they sort of
compensate if you go after the red piece
and we stop that mutating than the green
one will and so what David Nasim said
well why don't we look at the pair's
okay to look for pairs so that we can
stop this adaptive mutation and that's
the weak spot an HIV and what we can do
is if we identify those pairs we can
sort of train the immune system to go
after those spots ok on the HIV virus
and that is what the team has done and
what they've done is they've applied
machine learning against a massive data
set what's interesting is to do this
what you would typically do is you would
take a single patient take a blood
sample sequence it look at what the
virus looks like then a week later take
another secret another sample sequence
that do that every week and then you can
see how the HIV is mutating okay that's
very difficult to do with one patient
it's much harder to do with hundreds or
thousands of patients somewhere like
Africa where you know getting them to do
that on a weekly basis is pretty much
impossible so what David did is in the
team was they looked at a single
snapshot of a population of thousands of
people with HIV and sequence those
genomes and they use the machine
learning actually to make that the
equivalent of sampling a single person
over time so it's an example and sort of
big data of applying the machine
learning to the dataset looking at it in
a different way and also you know coming
up with this novel way of trying to
figure out the weakness in HIV so it's a
good example I think in
in sort of health care of big data
machine learning to go after a sort of
big problem cloud computing so let me
talk to you a little bit about cloud
computing so the video actually shows
I'll point you to the URL for the video
where David and his team are actually
looking at lots of different diseases
and running on I think 27,000 cores on
agile to do an analysis across different
diseases to look at that so the cloud
that Microsoft has not just windows
agile but everything so this includes
you know Alec calm it includes big maps
it includes Xbox we have lots of data
centers around the world we have the big
data centers that you'll see there we
also have what are called edge
facilities that allow us to do global
data distribution and so we have one of
the biggest sort of data center networks
in the world as you might expect and so
those data centers have evolved over
time from just racks of boxes okay to
sort of high density rack so this is
pretty much what most server rooms if
you go up to the sixth floor here our
server rooms got a bunch of these racks
okay and then what happened what we call
generation three was people came up with
the idea of using shipping containers
okay and actually putting the racks in a
shipping container because then we can
stack them up build our data centers
very quickly and that's really good so
you just plug in power you plug in water
cooling network you put in a container
maybe a couple of thousand servers you
let that run basically when enough
servers failed you can just take the
whole container out put a new container
and you don't replace individual
machines that was pretty much
state-of-the-art this team called global
foundation services this is a great
website if you're interested in sort of
what goes on behind the scenes in cloud
does a lot of R&D on okay well how do we
make our datacenters better so they came
up with the fact that these containers
are designed to ship cuddly toys and
electronics over the seas okay these
containers have been around for a long
time and their standardized so you can
stack them on a ship take them off a
ship stick them on a truck stick them on
train and transport them they were not
designed to efficiently house 2000
service okay we sort of crowbarred that
in so the team in global foundation
services said okay well let's start from
a blank sheet we still like the idea of
containerized data centers but what
happens if we we start from scratch Nick
I up with this idea called IT pack which
our latest data centers have and there's
a little video here which doesn't have
sounds or okay I have which shows you or
should show you when I hit play what one
of those containers look like so these
containers are now being deployed in
some of our newest data centers and
what's interesting is by designing them
from scratch we can really optimize sort
of how they behave there's a thing
called pua which is kind of basically a
ratio of how much power we were putting
in to a server a data center versus how
much power is required to power the
server okay so it's the overhead of
power so typically the pua of a normal
date sensor at your university the pua
would be something like 1.5 1.8 so
there's essentially fifty to eighty
percent extra energy going in to the
data center to cool typically cool the
servers okay with the new IT packs or
with the generation three the pua was
about 1.25 1.3 so the wastage extra
energy was 25,000 with these IT packs
we're using some very interesting
cooling technology evaporative cooling
technology but even then we're putting
them and using free air cooling where we
don't even need to use the water okay to
do that where we can get now down to
pier ease of around 1.1 so there's only
ten percent extra energy going into that
data center in order to cool cool the
servers so so again this shows you how
different think about this compared to a
steel shipping container okay and how
much more thought has gone into the
design so here it's interesting it shows
the outside temperature versus the
temperature and humidity of the service
and it can shows how the system's
changing you all to the airflow in order
to get the service at the right time
the other thing we do is we run the
service hotter than you might normally
do they're still within the bounds of
the like the process and manufacturers
okay so they're still operating within a
you know within bounds design bounds but
if you run them a bit higher viously
don't have to cool them quite as much so
you say when you scale that across
thousands or millions of servers
globally that's a huge saving on on
power so it kind of shows you kind of in
our cloud data center how you know we
can really with careful design optimize
how we operate the servers in order to
keep our energy consumption down you
know reduce our carbon footprint you
know and so there's quite a nice fatigue
I think that videos on YouTube as well
so we're going to talk a lot more about
as well but this is kind of you know a
high level of what Asher is it's
building blocks ok different pieces that
you can put together to build whatever
you want to build and it's quite
complicated there's quite a lot to it
it's not just the m's people think about
cloud as just virtual machines and
that's true but with windows azure we
provide lots of different i say building
blocks and Carlos will be going through
that straight after this lecture so
we've been looking at uses of cloud
computing across different research
areas and so things like protein folding
so looking at how things like viruses
mutate this is good for things like drug
design civil protection so that's
looking at how we can predict fire
outbreaks okay and looking at sort of
mineral extraction from France looking
at MRI of the brain for instance and
also in Japan looking at things like you
know internet sort of word analysis so
where cloud computing is quite
interesting is it essentially like so it
gives you access to very large amounts
of compute so one of the projects we did
with Newcastle University and various
other partners was looking at what's
called cuse are so this is looking at
the toxicity of a drug
okay so it's trying to figure out dosage
of a drug a new drug so basically
previously to run this on a sort of a
single server which is what they would
do to do this big study it might take
them it took them fight it would take
five years to run this case and so what
they could do is is the newcastle team
actually ported this on to the cloud
using something called e-science central
which is a nice kind of workflow system
and they could get that down to ten
hours because what you could do is you
could fire up hundreds of servers okay
and this was sort of pretty much
embarrassingly parallel and you could do
that very quickly now you can do that in
a supercomputer center okay if you have
access to a supercomputer center
supercomputers are great I Mississippi
compute person they typically will have
very high performance network
interconnects very low latency which are
very good and necessary for things like
weather forecasting for things like that
this they're not necessary for
embarrassingly parallel and so that's
kind of one applications where clouds
very interesting because I can spin up a
thousand nodes and spin them down it
costs the same for me to run one node
for a thousand hours as a thousand nodes
for one hour if that means I can get a
thousand times speed up and I have
instant access on the cloud then we can
do things like this and so these are
some of the things just quotes from
people on this project which show how it
really cloud is changing the way we can
think about using our computers okay so
it is that idea of sort of parallel
computing but a lot of its just the
access and the ease of use and you know
cars will show you some examples of that
interestingly as well with data so here
are some examples not so much in the
research realm so Transport for London
haven't you been to London okay quite a
few so London has a very big sort of
transport network buses and underground
transport for london actually make the
real-time data available over the web
okay when they did this they deploy this
in their data center or in a higher data
center and everybody started building
apps and essentially the system ground
to a halt and so so microsoft work with
Transport for London to take that data
feed and stick it up onto our cloud on
to actual so that it could scale out
with demand so they're just seen a
hundreds of apps now that are consuming
those live data feeds so it's a good
example where the cloud can do very good
scalable distribution of data another
example is ordnance survey so Ordnance
Survey is the UK's mapping agency and so
they have a full digital mapping service
so you can go onto the website you can
draw a box around Cambridge ascetically
give me a map at 5000 resolution and
download it and all of that data you can
imagine all of that high res vector data
mapping for the whole of the UK and
again by putting that on a show it
really helps them there and again with
data there's something called the agile
marketplace which I don't think I was
going to go through but here there are
lots of data sets a lot of them are free
okay and some great kind of data feeds
on there and one of the examples is the
UK Met Office which has its weather
forecasts available through actual
market place so you can program against
this and build apps that will pull
weather data from actual market place
it's not just data so there are services
so Microsoft translation service you can
write programs that will translate
between lots of different languages
including Klingon now a hair and and but
you can do it programmatically okay so
there are web widgets and things but if
you're writing a program you can
actually get access to that you know top
quality machine translation this is a
video about the fire prediction so again
I'll point you to that later so I just
want to finish off again looking at life
the universe and everything and that's
that Hubble image again I love with an
example of an end user application
called chrono zoom which is essentially
a timeline for everything okay so this
was developed by us and walter alvarez
at university UC Berkeley Walter's a
very interesting chap he was the person
who went out to Italy and was looking at
the rocks essentially because she was
hunting there and he saw that in the
rock layer when the dinosaurs were
around that all of a sudden there was a
big sort of definite line in the
stratification of the rocks
what he found was that there is a ridium
present at that at that line and iridium
doesn't exist on earth okay and that
piece in time was when the dinosaurs
were wiped out so Walter was the one who
theorized that the dinosaurs were wiped
out by a meteorite and then after that
people started to look for it and they
found the the Yucatan crater which we
think is the crater of the meteorite the
wiped out the dinosaurs now Walter's so
is interested in these very large
timescales disorder geologists so he
teaches a course in something called big
history and big history is trying to
understand essentially the timeline of
everything and it's very difficult to
visualize time from the start of the
universe 13 and so I think it's 13.7
little over 13.7 billion years down to a
single day in modern history so one of
his students actually looked at a piece
technology we have called deep zoom
which allows you to do through a web
browser zooming in and out and they
developed a prototype of that they call
chrono seem to do this and say I will
cry zoom project org so you can look at
that and I'm going to just quickly show
you so this is a timeline of everything
okay and in chrono see what we do is we
have what we call exhibits okay so i can
zoom in here and i can show different
what we call artifacts so when you go to
a museum you see an exhibit and they're
different artifacts and these artifacts
can be things like movies which is quite
nice so we can embed things like Vimeo
videos wikipedia articles graphics and
so within this timeline we can present
different like say exhibits and also a
bibliography so if you want to use this
for your research you can do that so
this is quite interesting you see an
exhibit and so we can zoom right in but
what's interesting is when you zoom
interesting than that
but when you zoom out okay you can go
back to that timeline so if you look at
here okay so you've got Giga years there
we can see the cosmos and I can zoom in
and look at the sort of earth solar
system time scale and again I can zoom
in and look at here for instance the
different craters on the earth so again
look at the timeline at the top okay so
so 1.8 billion years there so that's so
you can see how we've gone from cosmos
to life of the solar system it really
gets interesting when we start looking
at life okay and we zoom into the
origins of life okay and things like
bacteria and then we zoom into
prehistory ok so again look at the
timeline with zooming and zooming and
zooming into thousands of years and then
we can look at people okay and I think
we're over mi sapiens at Sur ok then we
can mean over here so this is humanity
so modern humanity again so the timeline
now is quite interesting because we're
getting into thousands of years and we
can look at sort of Mayan history and
then we can go in I think it's over here
United States and we can zoom into
Microsoft yeah we can zoom in here are
folks in redmond and then we can zoom in
here oh there yeah that was the meeting
we had just the other last year's
meeting in January that we had okay and
what's interesting then is we then can
really feel super significant because I
can zoom in from a day in modern history
and I can zoom out through life and I
can zoom out to earth the solar system
and then zoom all the way out to the
life of the universe so you can see
they're tuned again an interesting Saul
delivered through the cloud okay all of
that data is in the cloud delivered a
really nice kind of Internet experience
so that's very fun have a look at that
and I just want to finish about where
we're going so I talked a bit about
supercomputing and some
of you I'm sure you supercomputers to
your research this is kind of how a lot
of research looks today where you have
high performance computing clusters
national machines universities will have
big machines I used to it so happens we
had an 8,000 core machine which was
fantastic if you could get on it and
then you have everybody else and the
trends are that we're getting more data
it's getting harder to do the analysis
so our team in MSR is really working on
clap using cloud computing to make it
much easier for researchers to access
data analyze data share their results
again this fourth paradigm of data
intensive science is really really great
that we now have the cloud and we can
build solutions on the cloud so that as
we say scientists can be scientists so
with that thank you very much for
listening I'm happy to take questions